[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal sur tv 60,18 les titres de ce
jeudi 18 janvier
les derniers chiffres de l'insee le
montre la france a connu l'an passé une
croissance jamais vu depuis 2011 cette
dynamique devrait se poursuivre selon
les prévisions est la reprise économique
est-elle notable également dans les
yvelines
reportage est la circulaire colons passe
mal ce document datant de décembre vise
à organiser un recensement des migrants
dans l'hébergement d'urgence
une trentaine d'associations a saisi le
conseil d'état sur le sujet dans un
contexte de préparation de la loi
immigration invités de ce journal denis
allard président de l'association
accueil réfugiés 78 et puis les
premières livraisons du chantier sont
prévus pour la fin de l'année les
travaux du site de la mgen se
poursuivent à la verrière l
établissement comptera à terme 4 185
lits ont fait le point dans cette
édition
et puis invités de ce journal également
norbert pirro porte parole de victimes
et citoyens l'association elle vient en
aide aux victimes de la route c'est à
suivre dans ce journal
une croissance française quasiment à 2 %
en 2017 selon l'insee des prévisions à 2
5% pour cette année est la dynamique de
l'activité économique semble revenir en
france et comment les chefs d'entreprise
yvelinois perçoivent t-il ces signes de
reprise sujet de nicolas banderilles et
michael enzi d'euros et patrick jacques
de dixmude à une croissance moyenne de
100 % entre 2016 et 2017 c'est le
résultat du dirigeant saint quentinois
iftn spécialiste en prise de
participations dans les sociétés il est
à la tête d'un groupe de six entreprises
spécialisées dans la restauration et la
communication
oui je sens depuis quelques temps un
début de reprise principalement liée à
une accélération des prises de décision
par nos donneurs d'ordre est donc cette
accélération de décision est propice à
avoir filmé en plus de projets autre
entreprise à coignières cet atelier
propose de créer une stratégie de
publicité création de supports
d'affichage ou de logos alexandre david
réalise avec ses cinq collaborateurs
près de 500000 euros de chiffre
d'affaires
la relance économique est perçu à
travers ses carnets de commandes en
douceur 2018 on vise à une augmentation
du chiffre d'affaires de 30%
ça va se traduire par notamment
effectivement leur bouche d'un
commercial l'acquisition de nouveaux
secteurs d'activité on a investi
derrière envoyer de nouvelles machines
dans lequel on n'investit pour créer
plus rapidement à livrer plus rapidement
nos clients donc on compte aussi sur ça
pour aller chercher un levier de
croissance
du côté de soap emea spécialisée dans
les essais industriels dans
l'aéronautique le ferroviaire ou encore
le nucléaire
l'année 2010 est a été stable en terme
de résultats mais les signes de reprise
ne sont pas évidents ce qui est
important pour nous c'est les nouveaux
avions est le nouveau type d'avion qui
vont sortir ou les nouvelles centrales
nucléaires ou les nouvelles technologies
ça c'est notre métier est aujourd'hui
effectivement il n'y a pas de nouveauté
dans ces mille danser monde dans lequel
nous évoluons nous investissions à
l'étranger nous venons rachat
laboratoire en angleterre on s'interroge
sur d'autres pays européens voir sur
d'autres pays en dehors de l'europe pour
pouvoir effectivement les chercher des
relais de croissance que nous trouvons
pas suffisamment en france croissance
investissement et emplois la reprise
varie en fonction du secteur d'activité
les chefs d'entreprise sont unanimes sur
le besoin de visibilité sur le long
terme
on reste dans la thématique économique
avec une jeune start-up yvelinoise
depuis deux ans il pourra à développer
une solution informatique équipe ornais
qui permet à n'importe quel utilisateur
d'avoir accès à un ordinateur un concept
novateur au service notamment des
malvoyants les explications d'oreillons
du coup vous allez pouvoir faire des
messages écrits d'accord donc si vous
avez si vous vous déplacez avec vos
flèches au web à accompagner les
personnes déficientes visuelles pour
qu'elle puisse être autonome face un
ordinateur c'est le défi que la start-up
versaillaise hypra a décidé de relever
corentin voiseux et jean-philippe
mengual se sont rencontrés sur les bancs
de sciences po il décide en 2015 de
lancer le premier concept de pc a accès
universel aux francos
que seulement deux personnes sur dix
parmi les personnes déficientes
visuelles
on se rend compte que moins de 50% des
personnes âgées de plus de 60 ans
disposent d'un ordinateur à la maison et
on se dit là effectivement il ya quelque
chose qui bloque assistance vocale zoom
puissant interface simplifiée
personnalisable t'arrive de cette
solution tout compris entre 1500 et 2000
euros
voilà je pense que l' expo faire entrer
en la personne qui passe par lou au
moment où elle achète elle achète aussi
la formation donc avec le produit ont
fourni la formation pour que la personne
s'approprient l'outil dans tous les
usages qu'elle souhaite et qu'elles
puissent ensuite de manière autonome
aller le plus loin possible dans ses
usages
depuis deux ans 150 personnes en france
dont plusieurs dans les yvelines possède
la solution hypra comme cette cliente à
trappes et il ya un problème ou une
difficulté il nous appelle et on se fond
on se connecte directement sur
l'ordinateur et qu'imad à distance
objectif pour hypra dans les prochains
mois consolidée et enrichir ce concept
un invité m'a rejoint en plateau c'est
denis allard bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
le président d'accueil réfugiés 60,18
l'association a pour but de répondre aux
défis de l'accueil fraternel et des
personnes réfugiées dans les yvelines
alors la question migratoire qui fait
l'actualité justement le gouvernement
prépare en ce moment un projet de loi
immigration ont parlé dans un instant
avec vous il ya aussi ce document qui
fait polémique la circulaire colons qui
est en date du 12 décembre dernier
signée notamment par le ministre de
l'intérieur gérard collomb elle vise à
organiser à un recensement des migrants
dans l'hébergement d'urgence le but
c'est de redonner de la fluidité à ces
structures d'hébergement qui sont
saturés aujourd'hui plusieurs
associations c'est pas le cas d'accueil
réfugiés mais plusieurs associations ont
saisi le conseil d'état pour faire
suspendre cette circulaire qu'est-ce que
qu'est ce que vous en pensez alors les
arguments avancés sont le texte ferait
référence à un tri
un pays parmi ces migrants vous avez
utilisé d'abord la bonne définition
c'est à dire c'est sensé opérer un tri
est en vérité c'est censé diminuer le
temps d'attenté des gens qui arrivent
chez nous qui sont en situation de
demandeur d'asile l'écosystème autour
des réfugiés un peu compliqué en vérité
il ya des deux hommes demandent aux îles
qu'on arrive en france on est par
définition de vendeur de jeans
on attend un certain temps que l'ofpra
s'occupe de vous pour réclamer l'asile
et puis donc l'obtenir le cas échéant ou
non la plupart du temps ils l'obtiennent
pas parce qu'ils sont ce qu'on appelle
du bli nez c'est à dire qu'ils sont
rentrés en europe soit par la grèce pour
pour l'asie le prochain enfin le proche
orient est l'année de l'asie centrale et
pour parle à l'italie pour ceux qui
arrivent de la corne de l'afrique la
partie est la plupart du temps
l'erythrée sud-soudan parfois par les
balkans et puis dès lors qu'ils ont
centré là et qu'on qui se sont fait du
bli nez c'est à dire qu'ils ont mis
leurs empreintes digitales riverains
dans un fichier européen
si en france on découvre qu'ils sont
rentrés par ces pays là on les renvoie
dans ces pays là de manière à ce qu'ils
obtiennent l'asile éventuellement en
grèce en italie ou dans les balkans
alors ça veut dire que l'on fait un tri
mais il ya des doigts c'est prévu
administrativement il ya une instruction
de dossiers
est ce que propose la circulaire du
ministre l'intérieur cédant fait
d'accélérer le processus ce qui pourrait
être louable sauf que du coup ça devient
une instruction non contradictoire
c'est-à-dire que le dossier n'est plus
instruits ça devient une ouverture à
l'arbitraire c'est à dire que si lui
bahut le pot l'air d'aller très bien ce
nom vient pas trop on élimine sans même
respecter les procédures qui ont été
mises en place dans ce pays la retirer
en urgence selon vous en urgence jouer
de toute façon faut même pas l'appliquer
on a en france le
un droit d'accueil enfin un sens de
l'accueil inconditionnel c'est à dire on
ne bat le tri quelle que soit la
situation il ya une droite mise à l'abri
c'est ça fait partie de la grandeur de
la france de pouvoir recueillir toutes
les personnes handicapées en détresse et
quelle que soit leur situation
après on examine la situation si la
personne de rester effet devant d'asile
va à ce moment là mais enfin ça n'est
pas un fonctionnaire si bien
intentionnés soit-il de décider de
manière arbitraire si celui qui reste
grèce pas c'est idiot autant c'est
louable de vouloir accélérer le
processus se sont parfois ils attendent
très longtemps sans savoir où ils vont
on a des cas de personnes qui sont en
attente de demande pendant des mois et
des mois on les déplace de centre en
centre sans leur dire pourquoi et
comment
c'est pas très humain c'est pas très
digne faisons plus vite et le
gouvernement a bien raison de vouloir
mais mettons les moyens pour accélérer
les moyens de l'ofpra de manière à ce
que les dossiers soient traités dans les
règles le cul qui ont toujours été les
nôtres et que ça aille plus vite et on
sera tout ou on sera content alors pour
mettre en application justement cette
circulaire des équipes mobiles c'est
prévu vont être déployés dans les
centres d'hébergement d'urgence est ce
que ce recensement a déjà débuté dans
les yvelines
non pas que je sache et puis ça va être
compliqué parce que de toute façon
pour nous-mêmes fréquentes et parfois
des centres on voit bien que c'est très
compliqué il ya déjà des associations
faut pas croire que les gens qui
arrivent sont complètement inconnu ils
sont déjà parfaitement répertoriés on
sait d'où ils viennent on sait à peu
près ce qu'ils veulent et déjà les
travailleurs sociaux il s'en occupe il
en envoie à ccc la loi au minimum une
fois par semaine ils sont hébergés par
des associations pour les pour les
hébergements d'urgence 1 par des
associations qui sont financés par
l'état faut savoir que l'état verse donc
vous moi et tout le monde verse 40 euros
par jour et par personne pour ce qu'on
appelle l'hôtellerie c'est à dire les
nourrir les héberger la nuit et puis
faire un peu de soins sanitaires et les
aider dans leurs éventuelles démarches
administratives ça ça coûte 40 euros par
jour et par personne
sous l'égide de d'associations du type
la croix rouge
aurore acr dans les yvelines et c'est
ces gens être touche de l'argent de
l'état c'est déjà déjà bien bien fait
après ils vont à l'ofpra et puis il
advient ce qu'il a bien c'est à dire
s'ils peuvent rester ici veulent rester
il reste un schéma ce qu'ils veulent
rapidement ce que le temps file
mais la circulaire est que cette
circulaire contestée est en fait en
pleine actualité de la préparation sur
la loi immigration pour une présentation
donc la présentation à l'assemblée est
prévue en avril présentation du texte
dès fin février en conseil des ministres
écoutez à ce propos didier baichère le
député de la première circonscription
des yvelines député de la république en
marche
elle répondait aux questions de nicolas
d'andré aucune remise en question de
l'accueil inconditionnel des demandeurs
d'asile la deuxième chose qui est
extrêmement importante c'est qu'on a
déjà exprimé et ça depuis le mois de
juillet
notre volonté d'étendre la durée en fait
de l'asile qui est aujourd'hui à 45
jours et qui est une des plus courtes en
europe dont justement avoir plus de
temps pour faire ce travail d analyse de
la situation des personnes qui arrivent
en france aujourd'hui il ya cent mille
demandeurs d'asile pour l'année 2010 est
donc c'est un sujet qu'il faut prendre
avec beaucoup de distance et fo ne faut
je pense dire un certain nombre de
vérités sur le sujet accueillir les
droits enfin les personnes qui viennent
pour le droit d'asile politique
bien entendu un compte on ne pourra pas
accueillir tous les demandeurs d'asile
économique alors on ira les deux minutes
dans cet entretien on va aller vite
c'est une question compliquée je le sais
alors ce projet de loi a été déjà
présenté aux associations pas de texte
définitif mais des ébauches qu'ils sont
cons et et qui ont été dévoilées alors
le texte prévoit des reconductions à la
frontière et qu'ils vont augmenter la
durée en centre de rétention qui va être
allongée de 90 jours à 45 aujourd'hui
d'un autre côté on promet aussi une
politique de l'intégration plus forte qu
est-ce que qu'est ce qu'on pensait de ce
texte de loi quelles sont les priorités
selon vous déjà vous avez dit un mot
choc quand vous avez entendu la durée de
rétention bon je vous laisse apprécier
que c'est des gens dont on comprit de
liberté alors je suis venu ici librement
pour essayer d'avoir asile peu importe
c'est pas ma question
vous avez parlé ensuite de l'intégration
ça c'est une autre question accueil
réfugiés soit 18 ans pense que
l'intégration c'est plus une affaire
d'argent après dès lors que vous avez le
statut de réfugié en france vous êtes là
pour dix ans dix ans et on discute plus
dont vous bénéficiez comme un français
de de dettes sociales vous bénéficiez du
chômage vous subissiez l'aide au
logement tout tout tout tout le
dispositif social et d'ados aux
personnes en difficulté se déploie pour
vous sauf que c'est pas ça qui vous
intégrez la plupart des gens qui
viennent ici sont jeunes ils ont envie
de travailler
donc notre association prétend que il va
falloir que c'est les citoyens qui se
retroussent les manches qu'il vienne
leur apprendre le français et pas
seulement le petit à ce qui est prévu
qu'ils d'un niveau absolument trop
faible pour pouvoir travailler on leur
apprennent les lois de ce pays pour
qu'il puisse intégrer qu'ils sachent
comment nous on vive et si on leur
apprend pas ils le sauront pas ils
pourront jamais s'intégrer elle dès lors
qu'ils seront par les français dès lors
qu'ils auront
une connaissance correcte de la manière
de vivre de nos moeurs et d'autres
façons d'être et qu'ils auront des
réseaux amicaux c'est à dire que les
citoyens vont pouvoir les rencontrer de
manière amicale et bien ils vont pouvoir
s'intégrer devenir des travailleurs et
donc retrouver une partie leur dignité
qui a été largement perdues ne plus en
faire des assistés mais des gens qui
s'intègrent c'est pas à nous apprécier
ci sont réfugiées ou non mais si les la
loi de mon pays a dit sceptique là il va
rester pendant dix ans moi mon devoir de
citoyen fraternelle c'est d'aller vers
lui et lui dire mon pote va falloir
taper le français je vais t'apprendre
comment on vit ici et ensuite on va
prendre un petit va pouvoir intégrer
notre société y a pas de souci c'est ça
notre objectif mais je précise que les
concertations vont d'ailleurs se
poursuivre d'ici là la présentation du
texte en conseil des ministres qui est
prévue fin février merci denis allard
d'avoir été avec nous vous êtes le
président je rappelle d'accueil réfugiés
78 on n'a pas le temps de parler
beaucoup de l'association en tout cas
vous pouvez vous rendre sur le site
internet qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
pour plus d'informations sur cette
association qui agit dans le département
merci beaucoup merci à vous en politique
c'est un nouveau coup dur pour le parti
socialiste des yvelines après la série
de défaites électorales et à quelques
semaines d'un nouveau congrès qui doit
permettre aux partis de se relancer
une centaine de cadres locaux a annoncé
aujourd'hui à qui elle quitte lps
ils rejoignent le mouvement lancé en
juillet dernier par benoît hamon parmi
ses membres bertrand ou lyon le maire de
magny les hameaux mais aussi à lies
rabais fidèles de benoît hamon et
secrétaire départemental du ps jusqu'à
aujourd'hui à des propos collectées par
nicolas kirillovitch on a choisi de
tourner cette page parce qu'on considère
qu'aujourd'hui le parti socialiste n'est
plus en mesure de réunir la gauche
d'être l'appareil dans laquelle les
débats féconds à gauche permettent de
préparer les conditions d'un retour de
la gauche au pouvoir de défendre les
idées qui nous tiennent à coeur de nous
opposer à la politique de droite du
gouvernement
des manuels macron et donc nous
considérons que il est temps de
s'engager plus utilement de consacrer
notre énergie efficacement à redresser
la gauche et que ça passe par une
adhésion au mouvement lancé par benoît
hamon qui s'appelle génération les
travaux avaient été annoncées en
septembre 2015 puis lancer dès mars 2016
c'est un chantier d'envergure qui se
déroule en ce moment à las derrière pour
le site de la mgen une reconstruction
totale des deux sites rivière et
forestier est opérée pour en faire un
seul établissement capacité de 4 185
lits au final le point sur l'avancée des
travaux avec mélanie poker ici pousse
l'un des bâtiments dédiés à la santé
mentale depuis mars 2016 le site médical
de la mgen la verrière poursuit sa mue
quarante mille mètres carrés de surface
plancher un investissement de 100
millions d'euros
donc c'est pour la mgen un très gros
chantier
le chantier c'est un chantier à haute
qualité environnementale effectivement
la certification d étude a été faite
et puis nous avançons et aujourd'hui sur
la réalisation avec une maîtrise des
nuisances au niveau du chantier
un chantier qui permet de fusionner les
deux sites historiques marcel rivière et
denis forestier jugé vétuste
la livraison du bâtiment santé mentale
est prévue pour la fin de l'année 2018
le centre denis forestier lui continue
son activité tels que lui ne viendra
comme je le disais précédemment
qu'à la fin la réalisation laon
transfèrera l'ensemble de nos patients
et de nos résidents nous avons la chance
également que toute la production
restauration est située sur le site rj
ariane denis forissier donc on continue
à livrer la restauration du premier site
comme celui là si tu mens et la rivière
sans aucun impact pour nous pour nos
patients les travaux sont prévus sur
trois ans fin 2019 le site aura 4 185
lits ses 76 de plus qu'auparavant
autre invité avec moi sur ce plateau
norbert pirro bonsoir vous êtes le porte
parole de l'association victimes et
citoyens l'association vient en aide aux
victimes de la route on aura l'occasion
d'en parler tout à l'heure l'association
qui organise et pendant les faits des
permanences téléphoniques pendant voilà
les deux soirs de réveillon auprès des
victimes et des proches aussi de ses
victimes vous avez participé à ces
permanences comment s'est déroulée cette
période de fin d'année
cette période de fin d'année s'est
plutôt bien passé moi j'étais donc au
téléphone on a eu quelques coups de fil
principalement des problèmes piétons
vélos également beaucoup beaucoup de
problèmes au niveau des vélib
actuellement sur l'île de france est sur
paris
le piéton également puisque le piéton la
nuit le soir avec une météo qui quand
même pas très favorable dans des
périodes comme celle des fêtes
le deux roues motorisés non peu peu de
peu de soucis voiture quelques soucis
également
donc on a eu quelques coups de téléphone
oui j'en ai eu deux trois toujours assez
difficile et est ce que l'on sait ce
qu'on essaye de faire avec qui me
citoyen aujourd'hui on va monter cette
annonce qu'on va reconduire d'ailleurs
certainement sur les grands départs
très certainement sur les vacances de
février on va renouveler l'opération
parce qu'on veut être au plus prêt
aujourd'hui des victimes parce que les
victimes sont totalement abandonnés ils
ne savent pas du tout un problème je
vais juste non c'est un petit peu il ya
une aide déjà on peut le dire
psychologique alors il ya une après
l'aide juridique à une aide voit la
guerre psychologique
il ya une aide également juridique parce
que naturellement judiciaire rentrer
très vite en compte les enquêtes se sont
parfois longues on paysans kenney face
aux deux andy face aux assurances aussi
des enquêtes qui sont extrêmement
longues extrêmement difficile les gens
ne savent pas par exemple qu'il faut
récupérer le procès verbal de suite très
rapidement un procès verbal peut mettre
une semaine comme il peut mettre des
mois être récupéré dans mon cas je me
demande accident j'ai été mis dans un
coma artificiel pendant neuf semaines
lorsque rappelé précisons le pur pour
ceux qui nous regardent vous êtes un
miraculé vous avez subi un grave
accident de moto
et 2 ans de 2 ans d'hospitalisation
pardon une mise en coma artificiel c'est
ça oui neuf 9 mois du moins neuf
semaines dans un coma artificiel
plus de deux ans avec quasiment trois
ans l'hôpital de garches rééducation
j'ai été très bien on a très bien on a
très bien géré l'accident mais mon
épouse personnel navigant air france et
qu'à l'autre bout du monde
trois enfants petits l'aîné qui avait 8
ans le second 6 ans la dernière quatre
ans tout le temps on parlait de l'ong de
choc d'un accident mais la famille
complète à la limite
mwami dans un coma artificiel j'étais
préservé comme mon épouse a tout pris en
pleine figure et ce cas on l'a bien
souvent au téléphone
les gens qui sont totalement abandonnés
qu'ils ne savent pas du tout comment
faire donc on essaie de le soutenir et
soutenir psychologiquement et surtout
comme on est déjà passé par là on peut
les rassurer
je vous parlais justement des proches
les clips de sécurité routière dont le
rappelle on est tous touchés quand ils
osent concerne tous touchés tous
concernés d'ailleurs on a travaillé on
est référencée au niveau des pouvoirs
publics
on a travaillé moi j'ai travaillé en
particulier avec emmanuel barbe pour la
réalisation de ce clip où tout le monde
est touché et tout le monde est concerné
et s'éteint c'est un tsunami c'est
vraiment j'ai souvent parlé de
l'accident l'accident est une chose
c'est une bombe atomique qui tombe mais
vous avez bien souvent derrière l'ombre
de choc et les ondes de choc qui peut
arriver quelques quelques semaines
quelques mois quelques années après et
qui peut être bien plus destructif que
tout le reste
oui donc ça c'est important de suivre
les personnes tout ou non de l'accident
et après également sur les deux soirs de
réveillon en moyenne c'est une triste
moyenne mais il ya 40 à 50 tués sur ces
deux soirs de réveillon les causes c'est
des soirées qui peuvent être alcoolisé
s'est aussi beaucoup les jeunes qui sont
touchés par par ces accidents sur les
deux soir du réveillon alors
les causes oui les causes sont alors moi
je
je fais pas mal de choses au niveau de
la région parisienne je m'implique
beaucoup au niveau de victimes et
citoyens et particulièrement au niveau
des lycées des collèges
donc je vais très souvent dans les
lycées et j'essaie de parler aux jeunes
alors surtout pas les juges et encore
moins leur faire la morale surtout pas
on a entendu notre premier ministre
parlait ya pas très longtemps
dire qu'il avait perdu quelques points
moi également j'ai perdu des points sur
des problèmes voilà des petits excès de
vitesse un point par ci il m'est arrivé
aussi de perdre trois points parce que
j'avais pas mis ma ceinture de sécurité
sur quelques quelques centaines de
mètres donc je le dis je met à l'aise
les les jeunes les jeunes
au départ on a des groupes parfois de 50
60 80 jeunes
oui comment voit-il votre message alors
voilà il arrive la la la la la la la
salle est un petit peu bruyante et au
tout tout tout le long du déroulé
j'expose je dis voilà il s'est passé ça
ça le silence et ensuite les questions
et surtout la communication et les
questions fusent et bien souvent voilà
j'ai eu par exemple une question n'est
pas très longtemps d'une jeune fille 17
ans mon ami à 18 ans il vient de permis
de conduire on est allé fêter un
anniversaire chez ces jeunes conducteurs
finalement ils sont dans les premières
scènes d'action les premières années je
suis jamais allé chercher j'ai des
copains avec mon petit copain qui
conduisaient il a bu deux verres de
vodka
on est rentré en voiture après on était
4 est-ce qu'il était positif ou pas mais
j'ai dit oui bien sûr bien sûr donc
voilà ils sont il faut absolument les
conseillers ont alors dire ce qu'il faut
faire parce que ils sont en demande
ils sont en est bien souvent ils sont
allés coûte ça faut le savoir
il nous reste une minute dans cet
entretien on a parlé de votre expérience
personnelle qu'est ce qui vous a donné
envie vous anciens accidentés de la
route
voilà miraculé vous définissez comme
miraculé à transmettre ce message à
aider à aider les victimes et leurs
proches savez je vais vous dire une
chose je je me lève tous les matins en
me disant
pourquoi moi je suis là et pas les
autres puisque je suis passé de l'autre
côté de l'autoroute du mur mur en béton
et un motard je suis longtemps après
qu'un motard qu'ils franchi le
terre-plein central
c'est un sur mille oui il s'en sort donc
vous en avez 999 qui meurt pourquoi les
autres sont morts et pourquoi moi j'ai
réussi à passer entre 11 voitures j'ai
glissé sur 18 mètres et je suis parti à
plus de 52 m je monte à 5 mètres de haut
donc je suis parti comme un boulet de
canon
pourquoi moi donc j'avais quelque chose
à faire et j'ai effectivement quand je
l'expliqué aux jeunes
quand je dis voilà ce qui m'est arrivé
ils sont allés coûte automatiquement
donc je pense que peut-être un deux
trois quatre 10/20 je ne sais pas mais
en tout cas j'essaye de faire quelque
chose mais en tout cas vous pouvez vous
rendre sur le site internet de
l'association pour plus d'informations
le site internet ses victimes au pluriel
point org merci norbert pirro d'avoir
été avec nous je rappelle porte parole
de l'association victimes et citoyens
merci d'avoir été dans cette émission à
dire 'ça y le centre de musique baroque
oeuvre depuis 30 ans à la valorisation
du patrimoine musical des xviie et
xviiie siècles
une histoire commencée avec le ministère
de la culture en 1987 c'est justement
ministère de la culture à paris que le
cmb a fêté son anniversaire mardi soir
mélanie poquet et camille lambert était
sur place
[Musique]
pour célébrer ses 30 ans le centre de
musique baroque de versailles a choisi
de faire entendre marc antoine
charpentier compositeur du xviie siècle
moins connu que rameau ou lully faire
redécouvrir le patrimoine musical
français de cette époque c'est le mot
d'ordre de cet établissement créé en
1987 qu'il y a 20 ans et il y a même
encore dix ans on travaille on pas du
tout de la même manière et c'est surtout
cette évolution qui est notable
d'une part la mondialisation c'est à
dire que centre de musique baroque de
versailles aujourd'hui vraiment le
centre international de musique baroque
de versailles
et puis la deuxième chose c'est bien sûr
les nouvelles technologies le numérique
qui permettent de fonctionner de manière
totalement différent sur la saison 2016
2017 l'établissement a présenté +235
événements en france et à l'étranger de
nombreux concerts et projets artistiques
menées avec la maîtrise du cmbv composé
de 140 chanteur c'est toute
l'originalité du projet de la maîtrise
qui a été conçu en fait par olivier
démolis dès son arrivée en 1991
l'idée de construire un choeur écoles
avec des enfants et des adultes pour
s'inspirer de la couleur du choeur de la
chapelle royale un centre comme celui de
musique baroque de versailles qui fait
tant pour faire reconnaître transmettre
diffusé vous cherchez vous avez
il ya trente ans la musique baroque on
ne la connaissais pas beaucoup une
institution unique en son genre qui
souhaitent transmettre au plus grand
nombre
le centre travaille actuellement au
projet génération lully avec des élèves
et habitant de trappes la création d'une
comédie ballet présenté au public à
versailles et attrapes en mai prochain
on referme ce journal sur du sport
marvin petit peut être un tournant de sa
carrière le boxeur saint quentinois sera
l'une des affiches du mail et 25 ce
samedi à levallois-perret dans les
hauts-de-seine
face à lui samir kasmi pour remporter
une ceinture intercontinentale wb a à la
clé en cas de victoire marvin petit pour
être intégré le top 10 mondial des poids
légers ce qui lui ouvrirait les portes
du championnat du monde
voilà c'est la fin de ce set 8 journal
demain même heure vous retrouver le 7-8
l'hebdo présenté par vannes nicolas
kirillovitch quant à nous on se retrouve
dès lundi pour une nouvelle semaine
d'information locale sur tv 78 très
bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]